peter king's football morning in america
is live at profootballtalk.com 10
educated guesses on all of the 2020
off-season quarterback movement and
folks it's going to be crazy it's going
to be a full-blown game of musical
chairs and chris i still don't know
whether when the music stops there's
going to be more butts than seats or
more seats than butts it's going to be
nuts and there are so many guys
unprecedented number of guys available
and of course the biggest domino that
will fall or stay in place
is tom brady with the new england
patriots he is a free agent now as a
practical matter because surely his
agent brady teams they're having
off-record communications about what in
theory would be available if he leaves
the patriots so with that said what we
are doing today we will
try to match brady with specific things
we'd like to see him connected to not
just team we're going to take it
a little bit farther than that we're
going to try to be creative connections
we want to see tom brady make in 2020.
so since i haven't received the trivia
question i assume you have a trivia
question all right go ahead if i get it
right i get the first pick i'll get it
wrong you'll get the first pick because
as we know it's rigged well as we know
it is this tom brady he got offered two
years 60 or they're reportedly two-year
60 million dollar offer that the oakland
raiders are willing to pay tom brady
okay
in live with that all right which
division
does tom brady have the worst winning
percentage against minimum of five games
what division does tom brady have the
worst winning percentage against
worst winning percentage against minimum
of five games i'm going to say the nfc
south oh
wow wow
you should have known this you talk
about it all the time the afc west he
has issues going to denver obvious one i
thought that one was too easy i mean you
love saying that all the troubles he has
in denver i know i know i thought you
were setting me up i went next level
because i know he's owen two against the
carolina panthers over the last year
right right um but uh i thought i
thought it was a setup i thought afc
west was the one you wanted me to say
right and uh is that yeah because he has
trouble in denver and that's why the
idea of him playing for the las vegas
not oakland raiders is a little bit
kooky because he's got to play mahomes
twice a year and he's got to go to
denver every year all right so uh yeah
all right
you get the first pick then in the draft
of brady connections we want to see next
year with anything anything you want to
connect him to go what i mean
brady and gruden i mean come on i'm all
in give me my popcorn put some butter
and salt on and i'm all in i want to
watch it i mean what
brady and gruden this is where it all
began and now it's where it all could
end brady in the tuck rule against the
raiders and jon gruden they reunite
and come back or not reunite but unite
forces and i just think it would be so
fun to watch i mean they would
definitely
be
mother effing each other a lot on tv all
right just you know would they they
would they though i think i would i
don't think john can help it no matter
what who's this quarterback i don't
think he could help it and i think tom
will realize oh i could talk to this guy
like this this is not bill belichick
and i think they would i think there
would be a lot of that going on i do yes
um
give me a little flavor of what john
gruden would say to tom brady uh on the
phone once they they have a deal in
place oh i mean it oh hey man hey
it's a work work this is gonna be
awesome man i mean
you're gonna love the offense and hey
i'll do whatever you wanna do too man
you just tell me what you want we'll
figure it out man all right man love you
bro love you bro can't wait to get you
out of here bro see ya
that was it so basically the same the
same stuff he said to antonio brown last
year pretty much those are some of the
standard lines yes they are yeah
all right uh well for me and i don't
think this is gonna happen but
when we consider the struggles that tom
brady had
in 2019 yes he didn't have a lot of
weapons to throw to but the offensive
line wasn't very good last year for the
patriots and it's not going to be much
better this year with dante scarneckia
retiring that is a huge factor in that
you know if he's making the remember
when walter white made the list of pros
and cons about committing murder in one
of the early episodes of breaking bad on
the list of cons would be
dante scarnecki is gone so how about tom
brady with a team that has a great
offensive line how about tom brady and
i'm stealing one of your bits here
tom brady on the wall
they're gonna build a wall
you also you also could say tom brady
and frank wright i kind of like that too
when you consider what frank wright did
against brady and the patriots in super
bowl 52 and i'm fascinated by what reich
would construct to suit brady because i
think reich would come up with something
that would work very well with tom brady
but brady and the colts brady and the
wall right
you know it's most likely not going to
happen but man it would be awesome if it
did it would be and you know and and
just to add to that like you know the
whole conversation there hey i mean that
was certainly one of his biggest rivals
early on in his career colts patriots i
mean when brady first started the nfl
they were both in the afc east and of
course all those epic playoff battles be
very awkward to see him in a colts
uniform you know wearing number 12 which
andrew luck had just previously warned
too so uh that would be that i had that
on my list as well all right well brady
in new york i mean come on how can and
i'm like i'm throwing the jets and
giants in here together but i'm just
saying new york because like we all know
boston new york there's a great sports
rivalry there
that would be unbelievable to see one
more time i mean of course the new york
yankees are they are who they are
because they stole a boston sports
legend from a desperate owner up in you
know up in boston from the boston red
sox and then he came to the yankees and
boston was never the same and you know
of course all the rivalries and you know
the new england team losing the
undefeated season to the giants just so
many things going back and forth between
the two cities this would just be the
latest chapter i mean if he came here to
the jets the team he's basically just
whipped the crap out of the last 20
years and then he came here and took
over the team i mean again i know this
is not going to happen but just from
pure viewership
story storylines brady new york boston
all those things i think that would be
pretty cool
but which new york team is more
compelling i know well you can make the
argument the giants i think the giants
are more compelling i do i'm with you i
think the giant especially because of
the super bowl history
belichick was once there as well i think
all of those things yes i would lead me
to the giants being the more compelling
one
and here's the thing about the jets that
we need to keep in mind
adam gay and you know it's become sport
in new york for some in the media to
just criticize adam gase about anything
and everything gates has shown over the
years that he has the ability to take a
player and craft an offense for him on
the fly if need be they had to do with
tim tebow when he was in denver and all
of a sudden they made tebow the starter
and you know they had to go find plays
from air force academy that they could
jam into the offense to try to come up
with something that would work for tebow
gates i think would relish the challenge
of coming up with an offense for tom
brady and the the fundamental difference
someone explained this to me last week
between brady and peyton manning is
that that brady will bust his butt to
understand the offense understand his
role in it but he's not going to want to
go to the next step and basically be a
coach like peyton manning yeah right
it's just different right he's not gonna
be as obsessed but he will he will throw
himself in and learn the offense and i
think gace would come up with an offense
that would work for him if it would be
the jets all right next one for me
hmm
i'm gonna go tom brady and hard rock
stadium because for his career tom brady
has a losing record when playing in
miami now this bubbled up a couple of
weeks ago and steven ross the owner of
the dolphin said i don't know why tom
brady would want to come here because
we're rebuilding but then there was a
report after that that you know the paid
the dolphins aren't going to
aggressively pursue tom brady and free
agency well okay then maybe they're just
going to not aggressively pursue him i
mean if tom brady is interested in you
you should be interested in him and the
idea of him reuniting with brian flores
long term a long time excuse me
assistant at the new england patriots uh
in a a city where he has struggled in a
stadium where he has struggled in a
division with the patriots facing them
twice a year bringing the patriots to
hard rock stadium yeah i kind of like i
kind of like that connection of brady
having eight games including one against
the patriots in a stadium where he's got
a losing record over the course of his
career yeah it would be cool i mean i
mean i'm almost like i'm just intrigued
to see what he would look like in that
uniform to me it'd be funny to see him
in that all together but yeah him brian
flores it's another 12. yeah isn't that
isn't that bob greece's number that is
right you're right another
so if he leaves there's going to have to
be some serious conversations about
unretired numbers retired numbers
officially retired whatever the case may
be
there you know most franchises have had
a great player who's worn the number 12
before it's not going to be the easiest
thing in the world to say yeah tom go
ahead and take number 12. well yeah no
you're right i mean it's such a it's
unbelievable really the history of that
number and when you really break that
down it's it's amazing just how many
great quarterbacks super bowl winning
quarterbacks have all worn number 12.
it's it's pretty fascinating that way um
all right i got so many good ones here i
just don't know where to go i mean
there's the san francisco thing there's
cleveland oh don't do it no there's
cleveland and obj i mean there's a part
of me that wants to just pick the
bangles just to see brady and the bagels
you'd want to see i mean let's be
realistic
they're not going to throw baker
mayfield overboard with tom brady this
is realistic none of this i think it's
realistic i think my picks are realistic
well mine aren't i picked the jets and
the giants that's made it unrealistic
right off the bat that's not happening i
mean there's top top two top six picks
there and this one's not happening
either but if you just gave me my choice
man
would i love to see tom brady
be the quarterback of mike florio's
minnesota vikings
oh but i love it oh what would you do
you wouldn't know who to blame who to
yell at you would be in such a conundrum
because you'd be like wait it's brady
it's supposed to be great and what's
going on and then you might have to talk
negative about them and do all these
things and then who knows you might make
comments like he's horrible and then the
next week you might say he's better than
patrick mahomes you never know where
it's going to go when it's the
quarterback of your team the mike florio
vikings
i think we've seen how the vikings
perform with a quarterback who lacks
mobility
so uh i don't need to see that oh he
doesn't want to see that one
but but but there would not be an issue
with number 12. no issue in minnesota
you're right 12 is not retired fran
targon it was number 10. all right uh
last one for me
and i i'm glad you left this one on the
board because the most fascinating match
the most fascinating combination for all
reasons
is tom brady
and jerry jones
dallas cowboys put him in the silver
helmet with the blue star ask roger
staubach pretty please can tb12 continue
to be tb12 and not tb 11 or 10 or
whatever
tom brady and jerry jones that would be
i i and i'm tell you know when michael
irvin first floated that i thought this
is ridiculous and then the more i
thought about it it's like is it really
ridiculous is it really ridiculous that
a 78 year old owner who knows he only
has a finite number of spins left to try
to win another super bowl would believe
tom brady is better
right now gives him a better chance
right now this year than dak prescott
and you're throwing on top of it the dak
prescott is driving such a hard bargain
at some point do you get exasperated
with dak and say we're gonna tag you
we're gonna trade you and we're getting
tom brady yeah i mean i i get you it
certainly would be cool to see
i think it's crazy you know when i saw
those last week too and all that stuff
too i just want to go
yeah if you're 78 and you want to win a
super bowl your best press your best bet
is the guy that's that quarterback dak
prescott is better than tom brady that's
crazy talk right now that is crazy
williams shereen williams who's covered
the cowboys for years yes and grew up a
huge cowboys fan and wanted to marry
roger staubach right she was on the show
last week right and i asked her between
dak and tom brady which guy better
positions the cowboys to win a super
bowl this year and she did not hesitate
and said tom brady oh shireen you're
wrong i'm sorry i like you and tom's
amazing but there's just no way
you know there's no way
tom brady is is borderline in the top
half of football i would say i doubt
that like i told you before the super
bowl he's somewhere between 16 and 20
right now
dak prescott's definitely one of the 10
best quarterbacks in football and has a
bright future it's only in the community
to go downhill with brady so i i don't
agree we gotta go yep we gotta go sims
has brady and john gruden brady in the
city of new york brady and the vikings
i've got brady and the wall brady and
hard rock stadium and what should have
been my first pick but i knew i could
sandbag sims to round three brady and
jerry jones oh i want me some of that
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports